So, how ideal is an ideal cache?
Does ideal compare to real?
I want to go over some facts that
help justify the ideal cache model.
Remember that the ideal cache model
seems to have some super powers.
So a technical question is,
are the assumptions of the ideal
cache model too strong?
What I want to do now is go over
the justification from the original
cacheable VS model paper,
which was by Frigo,
et al, and appeared in the Foundations
of Computer Science, or FOCS, in 1999.
The first fact is about
the assumption of optimal replacement.
It's a lemma, and here's what it says.
Suppose you take your algorithm and
you count the number of cache misses it
incurs on a machine with
an LRU replacement policy.
Now suppose you're given
a different machine.
This machine has the same line size,
but it only has half the cache.
It also implements an optimal
replacement policy,
rather than an LRU policy.
In other words,
it has a better replacement policy, but
it has less space.
It's both slightly better,
being optimal, but also slightly worse,
having less space.
The lemma says that the number of
transfer on the LRU machine will be
within a factor of 2 of the number of
transfers on this slightly better or
slightly worse optimal machine.
Now, I know what you might be thinking.
Huh?
What the?
[SOUND] At first glance,
this lemma may seem a bit odd, but
here's a very natural interpretation.
Suppose you design an algorithm
assuming optimal replacement,
which is what we're going to be doing.
Then the performance of that algorithm
on a more realistic LRU machine will be
asymptotically close.
In other words,
optimal replacement isn't as strong
an assumption as you might think.
Now, there's a more specific, technical
requirement which is one of regularity.
We say QOPT is regular if it's big
O of QOPT with twice the cache.
In other words,
let's say you design an algorithm and
you find out what QOPT is on a machine
with an optimal replacement policy.
What you calculate for
QOPT is regular if QOPT is big
O of QOPT with twice the cache.
So, if you can show that QOPT
is regular in this sense,
then QLRU will be proportional to QOPT.